je sais qu'à certains chroniqueurs qui
ont écrit une lettre à quelqu'un qui
leur étaient chers qui veut kif qui vont
lire une qui vole à présent j'ai vous
l'avez écrit vous avez craint pas tout
j'ai écrit une lettre à fatto est allé à
tous allez pas là et pas sophie davant
j'aime ton prénom
donc c'est sa fiancée cet avion si sa
fille un gma sont égales arguèrent mois
qui vient de le larguer elle sera tout à
fait encore les actions c'est qu'il a
l'art y est c'est très bien c'est une
aide pour la récupérer à la corde le
récupérer on va voir je vous regarde
vous comme si vous étiez fan hockey
fatou j'aime ton prénom que j'aime tes
mots j'aime ton âme
j'aime ton corps j'aime tes regards et
même des absences
je les aime car elle renforce mon amour
mais c'est ton coeur qui m'embrasse
j'aime la vie avec toi car sans toi ce
n'est pas la vie c'est un désert où même
le sable se fossilise alors y'a qu'à
tous qu'il est moi j'aime quand tu
fermes ta gueule
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
e
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
isabelle wissam al souffrent parce que
je suis pas romantique un pour le marc
hé regardez à la crise est à son mari à
lui à toi mon homme j'aime parce que
nous avons réussi à être presque vieux
sans être complètement adultes parce que
nous avons s'ils peuvent ou pas c'est le
temps que nous avons encore nos meubles
d'étudiants parce que nous on toujours
l'amour et l'humour et surtout parce que
nous rions toujours ensemble entre deux
engueulades et 3 g alors oui alain comme
dit l'autre je t'aime plus qu'hier et
moins que demain alors invincible
on a un tweet n'y en a plus d'alain qui
dit qui est cette personne
on a tué allez on va demander à aller à
raymond bourré mon moi j'ai moi c'est
les persans alors des personnes qu'on
aime les personnes qui j'en avais plein
j'en avais plein de ce qui m'arrive est
plein de choses ces dernières années je
ne vais pas m'excuser mais comme je vais
quand même aller quand même prendre mes
enfants en fait parce que j'ai deux
enfants formidables tristan je suis fier
de toi tu fais tout ce que je ne fais
pas tu travaille bien à l'école tu fais
des études de chimie tu m'a scotché donc
tu m'aides à tous les jours hatton à
tenir debout et à me battre pour vous
audrey tu fais aussi des études
formidables et je t'aime ma fille malgré
ton parcours
je t'aime beaucoup et je veux que tu
continues aussi tes études
en ce moment je vous vois pas beaucoup
parce que je pars très tôt je rentrais
tard mais on va prendre du temps
ensemble et voilà je voulais dire à mes
enfants que je les aime très très fort
ah les gens me ou mathieu et après
j'aurais une lettre pour ce que j'ai
écrit un poème mai ah oui bon il va être
à l'aise y apprend phrases ont mis à les
y met mais moi je pleure vite mais il
est pour mon ami jean me ayé but parce
que c'est vraiment un ami j'ai eu besoin
alors c est ridicule cher j'ai remis une
poésie à mon niveau littéraire c'est
dire si ces faibles sans me juger dès le
début dans tpm paix tu m'as accepter ta
culture tu as eu un peu me l'inculquer
chaque semaine c'est toi c'est avec des
sushis qu'on a dîné c'est vrai quand
j'ai pété un plomb seul toit savait me
calmer quand j'étais triste lerner dans
ta chambre d'amis un lit tu dépliait de
mes amis aujourd'hui et puis le pilier
alors merci d'être mon meilleur ami et
pas que dans tpm p
ce que vous adorez cette séquence lan
fait plaisir cette séquence est
tellement merveilleux qui dévalorise
dans l'émission ils font faisant croire
qu'il est radin qui n'est pas sensible
accès à naître qui est tout en
sensibilité que je l'adorent évidemment
jean mitaine lève toi ou une petite led
face caméra et pour mathieu non non mais
il sait tous que le bien que je pense de
lui on s'ouvre ce soir passe bien si tu
me vois tellement que tu ne me regardent
plus pourtant moi je n'ai d'yeux que
pour toi si je travaillais moi je
passerai mes journées à tomates et en
replay à écouter des paroles qui
coulerait dans ma gorge qui ont du bon
miel
je serai toujours là pour toi je t'aime
chérie
risque 10 ans tous les jours je vois
plus que mes enfants à saint malo
rizières avec la longue à venir
embrasser mathieu pour le remercier
c'est vrai oui c'est vrai que non mais
parce que j'ai peur du corona bien alors